clayton kershaw of the dodgers pitcher
joining us on the program where are you
right now i am in front of wild berry
pancake cafe in chicago illinois can you
walk the streets of Chicago and nobody
bother you yeah so far so good now what
is your not even pitching in Chicago so
that's it's like you're sort of on
vacation there a little bit aren't you
yeah just a four-day vacation Chicago I
we're just I got my family here right
now and so we're just grabbing some
breakfast we did an architectural boat
to yesterday it's pretty good day
agreement starting pitcher an
architectural boat tour yeah I learned a
lot about Chicago what do you want to
know well tell me well uh you know why
it's called the second city uh no
because of the fire so it two thirds of
the city got burned down so they
basically had to restart so that's why
they call the second city a lot of
people think it's because it's second to
New York but that is not the case I like
that what else did you learn this is so
much better than talking pitching yeah
this is great well you know it's a whole
book miss O'Leary's cow star in the fire
thing yes that's obviously not true but
they didn't exonerate her for that into
like 1993 or something so 120 years
later she's finally off the hook okay I
like that yeah yeah and that's kind of
where I stopped I had to chase my
daughter around for the rest of the tour
so I didn't really hear too much after
that but you have a routine when you're
not pitching don't you each day you have
some when you get to the ballpark you
have a routine right yeah yeah I got the
same thing every four days that I do in
between get ready to pitch for sure okay
so what do you do today and then
tomorrow because you don't pitch until
friday against the Braves right yeah so
today is a kind of like a workout day I
threw a bullpen yesterday and so today
is kind of like like a total body lift
typing and run some sprints and play
some long toss and watch some video the
Braves make sure I remember how to get
those guys out it's kind of about it
does your wife understand what you do
like how great you are
probably probably not like that no I
mean I bet you could ask her she's right
here but I don't think though yeah I am
curious like my wife really doesn't know
like she knows what I do but she doesn't
know like she can't put it into
perspective when your wife goes to games
does she does she know understand just
how difficult this is um I don't know
you know she I would I don't think
anybody really knows until you're in it
you know i just i don't think anybody
has the respect of what you do until you
actually do it you know so you know your
peers and the other respect to your
peers that's probably the most important
thing and I mean she's learned so much
about baseball it's unbelievable I mean
she knew nothing when we first started
dating and now she can actually like ask
questions after the game about why the
manager made certain moves us though she
doesn't she doesn't love baseball but
she knows a lot about it how can I talk
to Ellen do you want to talk to Alan
yeah alright yeah ok hey on Dan pack hi
Ellen oh you how's it going it's it's
great but I I'm curious how much bait so
when you first meet Clayton when does
baseball become you know when when does
that topic get brought up that he wanted
to play baseball know that you liked
what he did for a living oh we started
dating our freshman year of high school
so I mean it wasn't even on like a radar
at that point now was he what was
Clayton like as a freshman in high
school he was the class clown he was
much shorter than he is now a little bit
chubbier actually a lot of its of years
and uh I mean she was quiet but he was
like a kind of the class clown and had
tons a good friend so it was fun it was
fun meeting him when he was 13 years old
what's it like to watch him pitch when
you go to the game it used to be
absolutely nerve-wracking I mean I like
couldn't handle it but I just I think a
couple years into it I just had to give
it up and realize that he's going to do
what he does best and it's got to be
just fun for me to watch it because i
know that this chapter is going to be so
short and pleading that we just need to
enjoy it and not just you know live and
breathe every
strikeout so it's become way more
enjoyable especially now that we have a
daughter that is keeping us very
distracted during games now what about
when he comes home are you allowed to
talk about the game yeah you know he's
really good he leaves and at the field I
mean he's he can talk about it and I can
ask my questions and if he's had a rough
day we can definitely debrief about it
but he's not someone that carries the
emotion back with him where he's just
going to be in a bad mood the rest the
day or the next couple days so really
thankful for that you're a better
interview I think than Clayton Ellen I
can talk to anybody uh let me talk to
Clayton before I say goodbye and enjoy
the stay in Chicago oh thanks so much
for you yeah there you go how'd it go so
a little short a little chubby when
you're a freshman in high school yeah
how is the center house she always
thought they'd let me go wait you were
you played football back in yeah
freshman year I quit after freshman year
but I was Stanford center that's like
the whole story I got to snap the
Matthew staff oh that's a big deal yeah
so you had Stafford's him well we see on
the shotgun or was he understand what a
bit yeah we're Shaka uh I was looking at
your numbers when you first got called
up in what was that 2008 yeah do you
remember like if I looked at those
numbers and I said that guy is going to
be one of the great pitchers of all time
or a hall-of-fame pitcher would anybody
believe me if I said the guys Owen three
their baton 300 year walks were up
really high I mean what was the
difference in the last couple of years
when did it click yeah I don't know you
know I think when I came up there's a
lot of things I wasn't obviously wasn't
as prepared as i would have liked to
have been i think i was just a little
bit in all of being in the big leagues
and didn't really think that I had I
didn't really like think I belong you
know and just kind of took a you know
it's a little bit overwhelmed by the
situation but I'm thankful I got the
chance to take my lumps in the big
leagues i was i was awesome and it
wasn't until I learned a third pitch you
know I was thrown fastball and curveball
and one throwing my curveball for strike
so you know most games I was basically
just throwing a heater and that's not
going to work up here and
so you know I think it was 2009 the
second half of that that I started
throwing a slider a little bit and
figuring that out and I've just gained
more and more confidence with that and I
mean that really has been the biggest
game changer for me you said that you
old stop and watch there's a few
pitchers in one is Jake Arrieta what did
you think watching him in person last
night yeah yeah fun you know the balls
moving all over the place you know I
think you know the guys come back know
they gotta say man I think I was right
on that and then they say roll over it
or you know it's just a late movement
that he has on his pitches and you know
last night he used striking lefties out
with the change-up and I didn't even
know he threw a changeup so that was uh
I mean it was nasty so he's got four
legitimate said I can understand why
he's having a success he's having our
pictures allowed to celebrate uh what do
you mean during the gleam after strep no
I mean we're supposed to get guys out
you know I mean it's hard to hit so I
you know I think in big situations big
key outs you know there's going to be
some excitement and some emotion that
comes out but I mean you know after
every strikeout if you're dancing around
it's probably a little much are you
allowed to celebrate as a hitter um yeah
I mean it hitting's hard you know I
think I think there's a there's always a
limit to it for sure but you know I
understand a big hit in a big situation
I mean if you're fist-pumping a single
or if you're pimping a single when
you're up ten nothing or you're down to
nothing I mean I think that's probably a
little aggressive but there's there's
always limits but I'm okay with it for
the most part you know what pitcher has
the most hits since 2011 I do not know
you no way that can't be true yeah I
think so no just a lot of flap singles I
got him not up there really cranky is
second uh oh hey I gotta tell your love
you got 68 he's got 67 I am and then
it's uh Madison Bumgarner's in there as
well yeah those guys have pop hey they
hit homers and doubles I just slap
singles so I got the slugging percentage
I'm sure maybe you got one homer that's
all you need man yeah I'm done I thought
I need it that's good that's all you
need
okay and i know you took time out enjoy
your breakfast tell Ellen thank you it
was great talking to all right well
thanks all right as Clayton Kershaw the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience